[Music]
what was your lip-sync for your life
moment of the season
[Music]
that's lip-sync mama the whole seasons
clearly Monet trying to fake split job
be ridiculous for pound the alarm
[Music]
the fake-out I get tweeted and and
Instagram beyond that thing all day all
night long and it's cool to see people
really latched on to something that I do
back at home and have fun okay yeah some
of your sisters here tonight have said
they've stolen that move I think we all
have pulled it at some point now cease
and desist okay I know that dusty ray
bottoms when she heard that she was
gonna be doing Nicki Minaj with Monet
exchange she was like and RuPaul said
the right day for the ladies watching
from the back that is what we call a
lip-synch for your life and I know he
wasn't just talking about my my good
sister it should have been a double save
that day such a shame it wasn't oh the
double Shante you stay of course between
your Rica and I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
both of them were like I'm not going I'm
not leaving and so very Jennifer
Holliday Cameron Michaels versus Yuriko
era legendary I think my favorite
lip-sync moment had to have been Asia
O'Hara turning it out in groove is in
the heart
[Music]
she was just embodying every every
essence of the song giving me the
perfect deal 895
[Music]
the big thing and Monique art I like
that one Monique art when she was trying
to do a cartwheel but that she thought
mold I thought it was so funny
durable car will Harlow it was iconic
Volvo
do you know the lyrics yet you know I
have not I said no we won't do her I'm
not less than at know like starred if I
hear any of her music now I get trigger
PTSD America
[Music]